so we have this question that says
millions of Americans rely on caffeine
to get them up in the morning and that
is probably true although for me if I
drink even a little bit of caffeine in
the morning I won't be able to sleep
that night
here's nutritional data on some popular
drinks at Ben's beans coffee shop and so
we have the names of different drinks
and for each of those drinks we know not
only their name we know whether they are
hot or cold you know meet calories they
contain sugar content caffeine all right
now with that let's try to answer these
questions and like always try to pause
the video and see if you can answer
these questions before I do and on this
one on the right there's a little bit
below what you see there's a little bit
below and actually I'll just leave it
there so the individuals in this dataset
are so when you see the term individuals
you might immediately say oh they must
be talking about people because in
everyday language when we talk about
individuals we tend to be talking about
people but in in the statistical
language it's really referring to what
are the different entries of the data
set referring to so each of these rows
of the data set they're not referring to
types of people or customers and things
about those customers so it's not about
Ben be Ben's beans customers I have
trouble saying that each of these rows
represent one of the drinks that are
offered at Ben's ad Ben's beans coffee
shop so those are the individuals and
statistical language the individuals
could refer to things what are the
things represented in that data set and
then we're asked the data set contains
and we're asked how many variables does
it contain and whether or not they're
categorical or not so first what's a
variable well the variables are what are
the things that are different about
these different entries about these
different individuals that this table
tells us about that this data set tells
us about well the name is variable each
of these each of these drinks have
different names that's one variable the
type is variable they can be hot or cold
the calories are variable the sugar
content is variable on the caffeine is
variable so we have five variables over
here the name type calories sugar
caffeine so we have five variables so we
can rule out the six variable choices
right over
so we're going to rule that one and that
one out and so how many of these are
categorical so a categorical variable
let me write this down
categorical variable means that you're
going to that dimension of the thing
you're measuring is going to be placed
into some categories or that variable
takes on values that are a name of a
category so for example drink name this
is a categorical variable because the
values that drink name can take on well
those are the actual names of the drinks
these are the categories you could be
brewed coffee cafe latte cafe mocha
cappuccinos so on and so forth so this
one right over here is this one over
here is categorical categorical now you
might say well what's another type of
variable well another type of variable
is quantitative quantity quantitative a
quantitative variable is going to take
on numerical values as opposed to
categorical values numerical values that
are measuring some type of attribute so
let's go through these so what about
type
well type isn't a numerical value it's
taking on a category it's either going
to be hot or cold so that is also going
to be categorical but these other three
these take on numerical values that
represent in the case of calories the
number of calories a serving has the
number the amount of sugar in the sugar
variable or the amount of caffeine in
the caffeine variable so these three
right over here these are quantitative
variables so you have five total
variables two of which are categorical
and three of which are quantitative and
so that is this choice right here five
variables two of which are categorical
the two categorical ones are well what
name what's the name of the drink and
also whether they are hot or cold